- This video was brought
to you by BetterHelp.
(light upbeat music)
What's up, everybody?
Helen here to talk about
a show so cheerful
that watching it feels
like sunbathing in a field of daisies.
(gun shooting)
Oh, sorry.
Got that wrong.
I meant Barry.
This HBO offering
from Bill Hader and Alec Berg
is a masterclass in great acting,
great writing, and great directing.
And the show just finished
its third season
with a finale so stressful
it should have come with a disclaimer
for people with anxiety disorders.
So, now seemed like a good time to dig in.
Here's the gist.
Barry is a marine-turned-hitman
who wants to leave
his violent past behind
and pursue acting.
Unfortunately, life
keeps getting in the way,
and he keeps having to do more murders
to cover up his previous murders.
Really relatable stuff for all of us.
If I were to cold-pitch
this concept to you,
you probably wouldn't guess
it would become one of
the funniest shows on television.
But, somehow, it has.
- I got a (beep) wife.
A (beep) kid now.
Look at this, look.
- Oh, that's (beep) crazy.
He looks just (beep) like you.
- I (beep) know.
- So what's going on?
Are we all secretly sadists?
Has Barry simply cracked the code
on balancing brutal violence
with offbeat humor?
(gun shooting)
We'll investigate in
this Wisecrack Edition,
Why We Laugh at Barry.
And, of course,
major spoilers ahead
for a show you really oughta watch.
But before we dive in,
we wanna thank this
video's sponsor BetterHelp.
If you're feeling depressed, anxious,
or overwhelmed these days,
BetterHelp can be an excellent resource
for feeling better.
Personally, I feel like
all of the stuff going on
on social media
and out in the real world
just has me feeling completely overwhelmed
and I could really use somebody
to talk out these feelings with.
BetterHelp's network of more than
20,000 therapists are ready
to listen and help you.
After taking a brief questionnaire,
you'll be matched with a therapist
whose expertise fits your unique needs.
And what's so cool
about a platform like BetterHelp
where everything is done remotely
is that you can work
with a therapist
whose skills might not otherwise
be available in your area.
Within 48 hours,
you can start messaging
with your therapist at any time.
When you do,
you'll receive timely
and thoughtful responses in return.
Additionally, you can schedule
your choice of secure phone
or video sessions
to receive counseling in real time.
In my case,
I matched with Sarah on Tuesday,
had our first session
scheduled by Wednesday
and on Thursday,
we talked out some of the problems
that I didn't feel
like I could handle on my own.
While she didn't solve everything,
she definitely made the things
I was dealing with
seem a lot easier to handle.
And if you and your therapist
aren't a perfect match,
it's easy and free to switch
to a new one.
So join the more than two million people
who have taken charge
of their mental health with BetterHelp
by visiting BetterHelp.com/wisecrack
or click the link in
the video description.
When you do,
you'll get 10% off your first month.
that's BetterHelp.com/wisecrack.
And now back to the show.
Since the show began,
Barry has descended
into ever-more-violent antics,
from murdering a perfectly nice detective
to going on a needless rampage
through a drug storehouse,
to killing his clients
when they have a sudden change of heart.
- There is no forgiving Jeff!
- Not exactly plot lines
conducive to great comedy.
To understand how Barry
keeps delivering the laughs,
we need to look at a genre
variously called "dark comedy,"
or "sick comedy,"
or "black comedy."
While humans have been laughing
since we were monkeys,
dark comedy is something
of a newcomer in our species'
collective standup routine.
The co-founder of
Surrealism, Andre Breton,
coined the phrase
"l'humour noir,"
i.e. black comedy, in 1939.
He believed that dark comedy
had an inherently modern sensibility.
Though it had existed in literature
and painting throughout the ages,
early dark humor mostly
took the form
of didactic, moralizing satire.
Modern dark humor, he thought,
was more subversive and aggressive,
and devoid of moral "lessons."
Which kind of sounds a bit
like our favorite show
about a hitman you
could bring home to mom,
but more on that in a moment.
But what about in American culture?
When it comes to film,
you can see dark humor
boiling up after World War II
in works like "Unfaithfully Yours"
and "Monsieur Verdoux."
As Wheeler Winston Dixon writes,
"In postwar America, and the world,
"the old social structures were crumbling,
"to be replaced by an emptiness
"which allowed greater transgression
"against perceived normative rules."
You saw this in stand-up comedy,
where "sick comedy"
like your favorite dead baby jokes
started popping up.
But the genre really
came to a head in the '60s,
once the studio system
had breathed its last gasp.
As Dixon notes, "In the 1960s,
"themes which had previously
"been dealt with only in
"the most serious fashion
"were suddenly subject
to burlesque, or parody."
Dark humor dominated film
in the rebellious '60s,
but mostly petered out of cinema
in the next decade.
On TV, "consensus television,"
i.e. inoffensive shows that tried
to appeal to the widest
possible audience, dominated.
Keeping dark comedy mostly
off the air
for most of the medium's history.
That's with the notable exception of MASH,
which used a war hospital setting
for dark humor
and social critique of
American militarism.
After MASH ended,
mainstream '80s television
was basically absent
of any similarly-dark humor,
although glimmers of dark comedy
emerged again in the '90s
in the form of popular
programs like Seinfeld.
- You know what they call him?
Soup Nazi.
- Shh.
- The balance of
chipper-to-cynical programming
changed as we moved
into the 21st century,
for two likely reasons.
One, the rise of cable,
and later streaming,
allowed for greater
creativity and innovation
as well as the opportunity
to appeal to more niche audiences,
i.e. people with twisted senses of humor.
And two, 9/11 and the collective
trauma surrounding it.
Much like the aftermath of World War II,
this collective trauma inspired
a whole lot of dark comedy.
Scholar Philip Scepanski argues that,
when it comes to dark comedy post-9/11,
"One of the genre's most significant roles
"was as Novocaine.
"By soothing the unpleasant feelings
"associated with events like 9/11,
"the sick humor of shows
"like Family Guy and South Park
"calloused the public in such a way
"that we could approach
policy more rationally."
Dark comedy, often political,
dominated throughout the decade.
But less-explicitly-political dark comedy
arguably exploded across the mainstream
in the 2000s and 2010s, too.
Think It's Always Sunny,
BoJack Horseman,
Curb Your Enthusiasm,
Baskets, The Good Place,
Rick & Morty, Archer, and so on.
Journalist Rachel Aroesti
argues in The Guardian
that the rise of dark comedy television
in the 2010s,
and the increasingly surreal dark comedies
of the 2020s
owe a lot to the influence
of the weirdos at Adult Swim.
And wouldn't you know,
we made a whole video just about that,
so check it out sometime!
The numerous shows that employ
dark comedy today
mainly appeal to millennials,
who, gee, wouldn't you know,
are more depressed, underpaid,
uncertain about their futures
and so on than previous generations.
♪ Baby ♪
(screaming)
- So Barry, which debuted in 2018,
was the perfect show for its (beep) time.
So now that we have context
for Barry's delightfully twisted humor,
it's worth looking at some of the tools
it employs to make us laugh.
Primary among them
is something humor scholars variously call
"humorous incongruity" or
"script incompatibility."
And yes, once somebody broke up with me
citing "script incompatibility."
Humorous incongruity describes
an irreconcilable conflict
between two opposing things,
whose sheer incompatibility
incites laughter.
Importantly, incongruities generally
rely on some kind of
transgression of norms.
We see incongruity all over Barry,
starting with the main character himself.
Barry is a hitman
who commits gruesome acts.
But he's also weirdly innocent,
all wide-eyed and earnest
about becoming an actor.
He's the perfect version
of what J.L. Styan calls
"the comic-pathetic hero" or antihero,
who is "capable of suggesting complexity
"because he has implicitly
"two or more sides towards the spectator."
He's a hitman
and an aspiring, mediocre actor
and we respond to him differently
depending on his behavior
at any given moment.
Pathetically, though desperate
to be a better actor on stage,
he's actually a pretty convincing one
in his real life,
managing to hide his identity
from everyone around him.
Styan notes that the antihero
"often tends to assume universal qualities
"through the very individual
"and contradictory details
"that go to make him up."
We can all relate on some level
to wishing we could trade
one talent in
for something more glamorous,
even if we've never
buried a dead body on a hill.
Because of his incongruity of character,
Styan explains, "We respond with sympathy
"and criticism, both."
The other characters
are similarly layered.
Sally is a talented actor
with a rich emotional life,
but she's also so self-absorbed
that it takes her forever
to notice that she's dating
a super-duper-violent man!
- Sally, you're dating a violent guy.
- What?
- [Helen] Hank is a ruthless mobster,
but he's also gentle, kooky, inept,
and devoted to Barry,
which makes his attempts
to be intimidating
generally quite comedic.
- It's me, it's Hank.
- I know it's Hank.
- I'm in a wig!
- [Helen] When he's confronted
by a murderous Barry,
who deliberates on whether or not
to kill him,
the supreme tension of the scene
is undercut by Hank vomiting
in relief when Barry spares him.
(vomiting)
- Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
I vomited.
- Hank is really
just the worst person to be a mobster,
and the "worst person for the job"
is almost always the funniest character.
Hank's not wrong when he laments that--
- Real talk?
I shouldn't be manager of crime syndicate.
I should be manager of hotel.
Chain of hotels.
- [Helen] Gene, too, is
full of incongruities.
He's pompous, but pathetic.
He genuinely cares about his students,
but briskly charges them for his advice.
- Now, I bill my private classes
through another loan-out.
So I'm just gonna go
and get that ledger.
- [Helen] Maybe most hilariously,
he's a revered and honestly,
pretty decent acting teacher
who cannot (beep) act to save his life.
- Stella!
- [Helen] Except when it
really counts, of course.
- He knows everything, Barry.
He knows you killed Janice.
I'm so sorry.
Just, let's get in the car and go.
- [Helen] And Fuches
is a total opportunist
and a user who also is devastated
to realize that Barry
no longer needs him.
- [Hank] You're not even
on his mind anymore.
You're not a blip on his radar.
- [Helen] These characters all contain
some inner contradiction,
what Styan calls
"an incongruity of the
solemn and the ridiculous."
What's more, because the show
doesn't encourage us
to judge any of them,
we're able to enjoy their hijinks
without pesky things
like morality getting in the way.
That's in line with theater critic
Walter Kerr's contention
that as a storyteller,
"It is better to make a man
"than to make a point."
But Barry peddles heavily
in incongruity even beyond
the characters themselves.
The world of the show
is split between
the self-centered ambitions
of aspiring Hollywood actors
and the brutality of
the mobster underworld.
And when those two worlds meet,
there's ample opportunity
for moments of pure incongruity.
Like when Barry's Marine friends
crash a party hosted by an actor
most known for playing
live-action Pinocchio.
Both sides are rendered ridiculous
by their clashing perspectives.
Then there's the way
mob life is presented.
As with Barry's character,
brutality is balanced with innocence.
Like how Hank worries
about finding "the right" heroin table
for his stash house.
- I'm seeing dining room tables,
I'm seeing coffee tables,
but not sure how to look
for table that I need.
No, it's for heroine.
- [Helen] Or how the mobsters all enjoy
Cristobal's self-help seminars.
- [Hank] Cristobal, their leader,
is guru mensch of highest order.
Like baby Tony Robbins.
- [Helen] The incongruity of mobsters
collectively striving
to be more actualized,
when their day to day job involves
murder and drug trafficking,
never fails to make us laugh.
Like the time Barry agrees
to train Hank's army
to pay back his debt
and make them as deadly as he is.
The innocent joy the men express
as they train.
- Hey, boss.
Did you see?
- [Helen] Is countered
by our sickly knowledge
that their new skills
can only be used lethally.
Or take the time in acting class
when Barry confesses
the story of his first kill.
On its own, this story
would simply be intense and disturbing.
But, it's coupled with the pathetic antics
of his not-very-talented classmates,
who try to act out
what they imagine
his experience might be.
The incongruity between
how they imagine his reaction to killing,
that he felt immense guilt.
- Oh, God!
I killed someone!
- Is countered by the brutal reality
of how he really felt,
elated and ready to bro out.
♪ Barry Berkman ♪
- And the acting class' inability
to even conceive
of what wartime might be like
is a crucial point.
Much of Barry suggests that,
by sequestering our experience
with America's recent wars,
we're forcing soldiers
to bear the psychological brunt
of the country's foreign policy
while the rest of us
remain blissfully unaware.
More on that in a moment.
Now, notably, a common incongruity
in dark comedy is killing a character,
and promptly discarding
their body and/or narrative.
They're never to be heard from again.
The ramifications of their death
go completely ignored.
Here, the classic incongruity
is between the seriousness
of a human life being taken away,
and the nonchalance with which
that deadly act is treated.
Think Brad Pitt's death
in the Coen Brothers film
"Burn After Reading."
Barry sometimes follows this rule
during the first two seasons.
There are exceptions, though.
Like when a father
mourns his son's death
at the hands of Barry's mobster friends.
Or the way Mr. Cosineau
is plagued by the loss of Janice.
- Canceled, why?
- Because Gene had a full on
nervous breakdown yesterday and left.
- Still, we're often allowed
to watch Barry's antics
without thinking too hard
about the people he's harming.
We're even spared having
to actually watch Janice die.
But in the latest episodes,
after Fuches outs Barry
as the killer to his
victims' various relatives,
the show keeps us laser-focused
on the consequences of his actions,
and the pain he's caused.
Not just to those he mercilessly killed,
but to those who loved his victims.
This is very unusual territory
for a dark comedy,
and we think that might be why
some people have commented
that this season feels
less like a straight comedy.
We'd argue that the show's ability
to be more humane to its victims
than your average dark comedy,
while continuing to deliver laughs,
is actually proof
of its profound success.
So what is Barry,
and any dark comedy,
effectively doing through
its skewed use of humor?
A lot of things at once, actually.
According to scholars
Chiara Bucaria and Luca Barra,
"Controversial humor is a way
"to directly expose
"what happens in the world,
"to engage with the truth,
"to confront and to respond
"to a reality that is already in place."
But at the same time, they note,
to be funny, such humor
"necessarily exaggerates, distorts,
"and deforms such reality.
"For example, through hyperbole,
"irony, detachment, and emphasis.
"Thus, highlighting the inauthenticity
"behind representation."
We'd argue that Barry
is using its hyperbolic brutality
to critique the devaluation
of human life in post-9/11 America.
This devaluation can be seen
both in wars abroad,
where soldiers like Barry
have killed innocent civilians,
and domestically, as it seems
like no amount of gun violence
will make American politicians
take meaningful action.
The character of Barry,
a killer completely desensitized
towards violence while serving in Iraq,
is an avatar for our country's
larger desensitization
towards the real-world violence
America has wrought
in its war on terror,
and the violence that's far too common
within our borders.
But is the violence we see in Barry
serving a larger purpose?
Scholar Kristin A. Murray would say yes,
arguing that "dark comedy emerged
"from significant shifts
"in people's relationship to,
"and understanding of,
"death in contemporary American society"
over the past half century.
Because previous generations
contended with world wars,
incurable diseases,
and generally shorter life expectancies,
death was a natural part of life.
Today, we're far more
distanced from death,
in part due to higher life expectancies.
She argues that
"this avoidance of death
"is entrenched in US institutions,
"cultural practices and
personal interactions"
in forms like the medical
and funeral industries,
where only trained professionals
actually confront death on a daily basis.
As a result, death has become increasingly
"medicalized, secularized and mediatized."
One consequence of this is that
"death seems more
conceptual than practical;
"it is like a concealed possibility
"rather than a certainty."
At the same time,
Americans are more aware
of more deaths than ever before,
thanks to the ubiquity
of digital media.
However, this kind of mediated death
is marked by what Murray calls
a "kind of disembodiment.
"a crafted, marketed,
"sanitized representation of loss
"rather than a tangible,
"traumatic physical demise."
As such, death becomes
this big mysterious thing
we don't understand,
but are constantly hearing about,
and that makes us effing nuts!
Murray argues that
"dark comedy is an urgent articulation
"of the tension between visible
"and hidden aspects of loss."
Scholar Paul Lewis would agree,
writing that "the apparent intensification
"of cruel humor in recent years
"reveals a widely shared desire or need"
to better understand
and learn to cope with death.
When we watch Barry off someone,
we're contending with those
realities of death
we don't typically encounter
in real life.
And we'd argue that Barry
does a better job
of forcing us to confront death
than just about any show on the air,
by finding darkly funny ways
to inject both drama and comedy
into each individual death.
- Looks like the Bolivians
made it here before we did.
- Well now, you can't
rule other people out
just like that.
- Now who's making work?
This was Bolivians.
- There's the incongruity
between the forgiveness
the two sworn enemies come to
in the third season premiere,
and Barry's deadly decision
not to show them any mercy.
There's the tragic irony
of Ronny surviving
Barry's attack in season two
and killing the jealous cop
who put a hit on him,
only to be shot dead by police backup.
And there's the mirroring effect
of two deaths in the finale.
One which we can see, but do not hear
and one which we can hear, but do not see.
(roaring)
(laughing)
Each one is forcing us
to imagine what someone's
final moments on earth
really look or sound like,
which is pretty metal.
And what we fill in the blanks with
is probably more horrifying
than any reality
a camera could conjure.
And of course,
there's the constant refrain
of Barry declaring,
after yet another murder
that he's going to stop being violent.
- Starting now.
- It becomes more darkly funny over time,
as Barry returns to killing
like a sugar fiend to the Nutella jar.
As we mentioned,
some argue that Barry
has become too bleak
to qualify as a comedy,
pointing out that the character
has become completely irredeemable.
And that the carnage
he's inflicted on the world
is too excessive
to allow for laughter anymore.
For us, this argument assumes
that Barry is trying
to make anything resembling
a moral point.
But, in the vein of modern dark comedy,
it doesn't really seem
to be doing that.
Rather it's, as Styan puts it,
trying to "urge a truth about
"the nature of people and things."
It's simply offering
an unflinching look at a real phenomenon.
The contemporary
undervaluing of human life,
and not letting us look away for a moment.
As Dixon writes, "Black comedy,
"at its best,
"permits the audience
"not a single refuge or crutch.
"Not even the art itself
"is left available as a refuge
"in which the reader may seek
"aesthetic solace and meaning."
There's no comfort to be found in Barry,
as every laugh is tinged with darkness.
And that's what makes it so (beep) good.
As we've said,
dark comedy has long existed
in various forms.
But in modern days,
it seems to pop up during times
of political and social turbulence,
like the 1960s,
or you know, right now.
Barry unveils the violence of our times,
while also showing
how it's papered over
by mass media conglomerates
who feed us hackneyed,
dishonest narratives,
no matter how funny their premise may be.
- But then she turns into stone.
But then she's still horny,
so she sucks and then eats his dick.
- It renders death vivid,
in a time when our only exposure
to our own mortality
comes via the 24-hour news cycle.
At the same time,
it forces us to reckon
with America's culture of violence.
All while being funny.
To summarize a Socrates line
from Plato's Symposium,
"Real poets use tragedy
"and comedy both at once,
"and human life is experienced
"as a mix of the tragic and comedic."
We'd argue that makes Hader and Berg
nothing less than contemporary poets.
But what do you guys think?
Does Barry straddle tragedy and comedy
while keeping its funny bone intact?
Or has the show gone
too dark for chuckling?
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out
our revamped Patreon page.
Shoot that subscribe button
like there's a tiger in the other room,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always,
thanks for watching, later.
(upbeat music)